and joining us right here from uh sports
illustrated and the uh man who provides
the mmqb every single monday he is
albert breer how you doing albert
i'm good how are you doing right well
the ravens got better today didn't they
yeah they sure did you know and i think
it's another good example of how
aggressive they've been the last couple
of years
and um and also the benefit of
of having a quarterback a premier
quarterback on a rookie contract you
know
you see what the chiefs were able to do
over the course of
um you know a couple years that they had
patrick mahomes on the deep
um you know and how aggressive they were
able to be and bringing in guys like
sammy watkins and tyron matthew and
um you know the ravens are still in that
in that category where they have a
margin
on a rookie context they've got
flexibility to
to be very aggressive with these sorts
of things and so you know
keep taking the chance of somebody like
giantic or something they could do right
now
absolutely and plus you know the the
three that they gave up for him they'll
get back in compensatory
and a compensatory pick if ngakwe
decides to leave but
i mean he'll look around and he'll see a
a a
a locker room and a organization in a
certain
culture and he might go deep into the
playoffs if not win at all and why would
he go anywhere and then there's the news
that
uh our buddy uh ian rappaport uh tweeted
out that looks like dez bryant's gonna
come in the fold here what do you know
about that
yeah and you know it's weird to see like
because of the new rules this year
um guys like that going on practice
squads you know like it's like you
almost have to take a double tank when
you see some of those things but um you
know they they had investigated the idea
of antonio brown and so i i think again
it's like one of these things where the
ravens really
as being in that sort of window where um
they are able to you know kind of go
take some chances right now because the
culture is good because they've got
lamar and rookie deal and
um you know it has sort of always been
the way that you know organizations like
that have been able to operate where
you know like new england was a good
example of it over the years where they
could take chances on guys other teams
couldn't because their locker room could
kind of absorb it
you know like so you know for example
like in 2011 the patriots take chances
on
you know shadow to cinco an albert
haynesworth and it was a disaster
neither of them worked out you know
but they went to the super bowl that
year because the people in the locker
room were able to manage it
so i think we're like bringing in a guy
dez or investigating a guy like antonio
brown
uh would be a non-starter from some
teams just because you'd wonder
you know could this send us you know
sideways in certain corners of the
locker room
um teams that are really strong in those
areas don't have to worry about
baltimore certainly been in that
category for a long time and they're in
that category now
i think they just sort of look at it as
a worthwhile gamble well
in terms of antonio brown i mean um
you know uh he he's just on a on a
different
level different plane maybe planet when
it comes to
what he can do with a locker room as
well as his
all-world ability just all in one
package that you have to wonder uh is
viable
based on the fact that he had a spot in
new england
all pretty much settled and then didn't
work out there so how real is his return
in 2020
and the fact that again pete carroll
went on sirius xm radio
uh last night and said we're in it uh
in response to antonio brown what do you
make of all this
so rachel you know what you just said
there at the start like raises an
interesting question which is
if he couldn't make it work in new
england with tom brady as his sponsor
right like tom brady was championing
championing
championing him i'm like i can't get
that word out of my mouth now you know
what i'm saying
yes uh if he couldn't if he couldn't
make it there
with that guy in his corner like is it
gonna work anywhere so it's a fair
question to ask
um you know i think you know seattle
obviously has history taken these sorts
of chances in the past they definitely
have
um and you know pete carroll is always
good at managing personalities so that's
the baseline
i also think though which is indicative
of where the seahawks are right now
um you know that defense has been
i think as shaky as we've seen it at any
time
in the pete carroll era which is i mean
amazing when you consider
they're 5-0 right now and so you know i
think you know when you look at
doing something with antonio brown
looking at the idea bringing in antonio
brown's acknowledgement
that they have to keep up what they're
doing offensively and
while they've got a lot out of the
receiver position dk metcalf and tyler
lockett
um they have to keep that up you know if
one of those guys were to bank
get banged up like you know it could be
big trouble you know and so
i think as much as anything else is sort
of i guess
like kind of an illustration of a new
makeup of the seahawks
um you know more so than it is you know
about the
the actual risk they're taking because
they've taken these sorts of risks in
the past and so
it's awfully it'd be awfully interesting
if we got you know
russell wilson who's absolutely
like this in the middle of the season
you know the league still obviously has
to clear him after he gets through the
eight games
and that's not you know that's not a
given but uh but it would be interesting
to see
you know what he would look like in
seattle you were about to go uh you you
went in the direction well my
my my question is next is what are the
mechanics of this i mean you've got to
get through week eight
it's got to be between week eight week
nine and then uh
whoever represents antonio now knocks on
the league door and says we're ready or
does he meet with roger goodell now
behind the scenes how does this all work
albert
yeah he has to be he has to be
reinstated um
and that could mean a meeting with with
roger goodell it could mean a meeting
with troy vincent you know there are a
number of people that could handle this
it's not always handled at the goodell
level you know but sometimes with
high profile cases like this you know
roger won't be involved and so
yeah i mean it's beyond the eight games
that you know were reported at the
beginning of the year
um which you know i think you know to
some degree the one nuance you want to
pay attention
to there like i think that was done to
some degree to do
antonio a solid in that saying like okay
like we're going to create some
certainty out there for you
so if a team is going to look at you at
least now they know what they're dealing
with
rather than you know sort of being in
this gray area that everything was in
for
for a long time you know the league did
do
you know uh did do antonio brown a solid
in in
in giving him like a defined time but he
still needs to be reinstated by the
league and
you know like i said like that sort of
with these sorts of things it's like
there's like an ongoing review
you know and and i do think to to the
league's credit they've sort of taken
i think more of a rehabilitative stance
on these things and you heard it the way
the commissioner talked to the super
bowl
that punitive you know which has always
been way in the past
and so i i think a lot of this is going
to boil down to roger goodell believing
that the best thing for antonio brown is
for him to play football
albert breer here on the rich eisen show
let's get to it what do you know about
the tour timeline where this came from
from
why now all of it what have you been
able to hunt down over the last 72 hours
albert well you know what's here here's
what's fascinating
like i'll start here baseline um brian
flores
is as good at handling players as
any young coach i've come across and so
my belief is
brian flores would not be doing this
unless he could sell it to his locker
room
and the fact that they're playing well
um
like kind of like up the ante there
where you need to have a guy who's
capable of like not just you know
planning okay but being able to kind of
keep going what they've had going on
so that's number one and then i think
you know from there
there are two pieces to this number one
is being realistic
organizationally about where you are
they've looked great
um i i think they're still probably a
year or two away and so i think you
still have to kind of think with that
vision which is
like what's best for the organization
right now like is it best for the
organization to keep going when we're
going with ryan fitzpatrick if
you know that means an extra win or two
at the end of the year i like
or is it or are we better off kind of
like taking a long-term view here and
saying
we we need to get to our reps so yeah i
think part of it's being realistic about
where they are
and then the really interesting part
about this rich is
you know the way that most guys get in
um both first-round quarterbacks who
um you know who aren't weak one stars
the way they're getting is when things
go off the rails that are terrible right
like normally you've seen this
i you you've seen this over the last 25
years
like what happens is team starts one and
seven your quarterbacks on a bad team
and they just throw them out there
because why not at that point right
um i think what's really interesting
about what the dolphins are doing is the
opposite of that
is that they look at this and they say
okay we're in our bye week and we're
gonna we've got the opportunity to give
this kid a really really good
healthy uh environment to develop in
and so they've decided to take that
opportunity and so from that standpoint
it's counter intuitive to what we've
normally seen over the last 20 or 25
years
we're first-round quarterbacks but i
think in the end it could wind up being
absolutely what's best for tua
well in terms of that too albert i mean
um i kind of just thought of this as you
as i was listening to you talk and i
have the schedule here in front of me
and the schedule i hear in front of me
is what it was
as a schedule when this season started
and the the dolphins buy was originally
week 11
and as we all know with what happened
with the new england denver game and the
reshuffling that needed to happen
for those schedules this week would have
been miami taking on denver
in denver that's been rescheduled for
later on
in week 11 when thereby originally was
do you think maybe the original plan was
let's give this 10 weeks with ryan
fitzpatrick and for sure
you know we'll we'll we'll circle our
week 11 bye is the time and then how it
got reconfigured it's like okay buys now
this is our shot
let's do it now do you think that was a
possibility i think it's
yeah i mean i think it's fair you know
like we've seen it before
and we've seen teams make like you know
i i get those franchise shifting sort of
decisions based on where they're buy is
right i mean you remember there was that
streak of years where like coaches kept
getting fired coming back from london
because
right yeah spy week was right after the
london game right uh
but it wasn't because the guys were
coming back from london it was because
of the buy
you know so um i i think what you what
you're saying
logically makes sense again i i i
hesitate to
be hard and fast with that though
because sure i just i
i just think such a huge part of this is
flo being able to sell that to his
locker room and follow being able to
tell the veteran players on that team
this is going to work and the only way
that he can convince him of that
is if two is practicing well if his 2o
looks good in the meetings
if two is attentive the two is a good
teammate like so
you know i do think like you know
whatever the best late plans were at the
beginning of september
and how that might have changed based on
where the bye week is
i i think the bigger part of this is is
tua really did have to earn it you know
he had to earn it over the last six
weeks and clearly
you know this is a quarterback now that
brian flores feels comfortable
selling to his team as the right starter
for them
as they go into the playoff run over the
next 10 weeks and
and the other reason why you know i
bring up the bye week
is um just in search of circumstances
that could have changed to bring this
decision on right now
right albert because it sure seemed to
catch
ryan fitzpatrick flat-footed i even
thought based on that fitzpatrick
you know rooting the fans to get louder
when tua did get on the field is a
a great moment of just camaraderie uh
and and the fact that you saw tua
facetiming his parents
in his full uniform after the game yep
i'm putting two and two together wonder
maybe is this a possibility that
two of the the changing of the guard and
it was known by everybody was happening
right
then and then ryan fitzpatrick said what
he had to say yesterday it made me feel
foolish for even thinking that
yeah i i don't think they i
i can't imagine they made it right after
the game right just you know
i think this is a big organizational
decision and this doesn't just involve
the coaches you know this
involves chris claire the general
manager the guy who drafted him you know
like this is a high level
decision uh because once you go to you
know a guy that you draft in the top ten
do you know this rich
there's no going back right like this
isn't like
okay like two will get in there for
three weeks we'll see how it goes and
all the [ __ ] we need to
but generally what you're doing is
you're going to the guy for good and
hopefully you're going to the guy for
the next 15 years and so
um and i do think fitz was was probably
caught a little off guard by this that
said
i think he had to know the score here
you know and that's part of the reason
why you bring him in because he's okay
with it and he gets it
um you know when you draft a guy that
high you know the same way tyrod taylor
would know that like eventually justin
herbert's time was coming in la
and obviously that came under really
weird circumstances
you know fitz had to know that that that
um
had to know that to his time was coming
i mean it's not his first rodeo
albert breer here on the rich eisen show
um
so then um 12 days to the trade deadline
we saw a big one go
today uh on defense what what are you
hearing
what do you think the next two weeks
looks like on that front
there's there's a lot of talk and uh you
know i'll give my i'll give my column a
plug i'm gonna have something up on this
later in the day but i think
one one thing that's one thing that's
going to be interesting um over the next
you know i think you know 12 days is
what you said right like to election day
when
which is crazily enough the trade
deadline day
[Music]
you know i i think next year's salary
cap
is going to loom large over everything
um
there's a chance the cap falls at 175
next year
um you know we could have lower caps in
2022 and 2023
and so there are all these teams that
are sitting there
and are already over next year's cap
because of the way they planned
and because of the way things changed 13
of the 32 teams a crazy number 13 of 32
teams have cap commitments
exceeding 175 million dollars for next
year
already today and so you know i think
some of the teams that
had um expected to contend but
aren't they thought they'd be will be in
the mix here i'm told the vikings are
sellers now it's not just
like they are they are listening on
everyone um the eagles they're another
team that i think could wind up dealing
guys off zachard's name was out there
he's sort of off the table now because
he's been injured but al shawn jeffrey's
available
so you know i think you're going to see
some of that across the league where
there are teams that have i think four
kneecap situations next year
that are going to make some players that
maybe you wouldn't have expected to be
available be available over the next two
weeks
could that team one of those sellers be
if you're talking about a team that's
not uh as good as expected and
has cap issues moving forward could one
of those teams
possibly on this planet called earth be
the dallas cowboys
albert what do you think you know like
so i made a lot of calls on this over
the last i'd say 36 hours or so
um right now they were the only team in
the nfc east that was not seen as a
seller
like i heard ryan kerrigan's name in
washington i heard kevin's i learned
golden tate's name in new york
i heard ernst i heard also in in philly
and they were the one team the dallas
cowboys were the one team where you
didn't hear about veteran players being
sold off so as of
right now i would say no
um you know it's going to be interesting
going forward because they do have so
many pricey veterans and
you know their cap situation is going to
be tight coming out of this year plus
they're gonna have to figure out what to
do with dak
but i i do believe this i do think that
the jones family
wants to get a thorough evaluation of
what they have in mike mccarthy
and i think it becomes harder to do that
if all of a sudden you're dealing off
guys for parts at this point
and while i'm already being blasphemous
could new england
if they lose to san francisco sunday be
a seller
do you think what do you think you know
i it's not the craziest thing in the
world
um if it looked bad on sunday
i i'd never seen that wrong with them
and i would have called them a buyer
um a week or two weeks ago um and i'm
not sure
quite honestly like what pieces they
have that would be that valuable
obviously like steph gilmore or someone
like that would be
um but and and i think there's a chance
that gilmore's not on the team in 2021
based on the way that things are set up
for them right now
i i would say that if it doesn't look
good on sunday i think that they explore
everything
and i i think the key here is that this
was despite the signing of cam
this was always going to be sort of a
turn the page sort of year for them
they're carrying almost
30 million dollars in debt salary cap
money this year
30 million dollars for players that
aren't on the team right now
and they haven't drafted well over the
last three or four years and it's
starting to catch up to them a little
bit
and so you know i know the plan going
into the year was you know hopefully
they built some draft capital for 2021
and then go into
2021 with like clean financial sheets
and they're still sort of on track to do
that
i like it wouldn't totally shock me i'll
put it that way
if there was opportunity out there for
bill to sort of
load up a little bit more for 2021 if he
it wouldn't surprise me if he found that
a little bit enticing all right last
couple for you albert breer here on the
rich eisen show uh got two more for you
why has adam gases bags not been packed
to use sort of what why has there been
no code red uh
to use the phrase of uh there's been a
few good men
uh that the uh jets have i'm already
hearing darnold's returning to practice
what is going on with that situation
right now for the team that said trevor
lawrence pole position
albert what's going on yeah i think i
think you have to look
uh i think you have to look to the
owner's box
um and strangely enough the election
plays into this
um you know i think the hesitance to
to make a decision at least in part
because
woody could be coming back soon and
whether that's
in four weeks six weeks whatever it is
like there is
a decent chance that woody johnson is
back in charge of the new york jets
by the end of the calendar year which
would put him
in charge for what could be a coaching
transition so
i don't know this for a fact but you
know knowing
some of the moving pieces here it does
make you wonder
you know if they fire adam gase then
woody johnson is going to be one the one
writing the text to him in 2021 and 2022
you'd be paying out that money to make
him go away
so it does make me wonder if sort of
all of those sorts of decisions are on
hold
until they figure out whether or not
what he's gonna be back from the uk
by november or december and so that
piece of it i think has been ignored by
a lot of people
but i think it's something that sort of
looms large over everything in new york
right now
and um you know the other piece of it
too is you want to go to greg williams
does that really make things better that
part of it
you know hey you know i think that's an
element too but i to me the biggest
element
right now would be the ownership
situation and the fact that woody isn't
here right now and could be back
within the next month or two and lastly
albert
um congratulations you made it big ten
week
the big ten is returning you were
pounding that table you're one of those
people
texting me about what's going on you
knew what was going on but you're like
hey
you know don't sleep on this could be
coming back here we are
yeah here we are it's not even it's
before halloween
uh big ten's back and um
how you liking your ohio state team
you're fired up i feel pretty good how
do you feel about your michigan
wolverhampton well
i'm very excited about them starting at
quarterback for the first time that
jim actually took out a high school he's
been using everybody else's quarterbacks
and
including shea patterson i'm very
excited about joe milton
i'm very excited about uh somebody who
might be a pamphlet shy of 66 240.
uh i'm very excited to see what what joe
milton looks like
in maize and blue quite frankly albert
yep
i uh yeah and you have reason to be you
hear good things about him just like
i've heard some good things about justin
field so i think we all have
yes we have to be excited i'll tell you
what rich like like all kidding aside
yes i'm really happy for the players i
mean like i really
i mean you know like one thing that i
was sort of thinking about over the
summer a lot like i've got kids in youth
sports and they're
a million miles away from ever you know
being there but
you know you think like kind of like
watching your kids you're like
it made me think like i was like the the
how how hard it is to get to that level
right like how much commitment it takes
to get to that level
yes and how short the time period those
kids have
to play at that level and how much they
put into it certainly when they were
four or five years old
i'm just really happy for the players
and that's for all
all the teams in the big ten and the
pac-12 that they were able to figure
this out because
that's who i think we should have been
focused on all along you know like that
those guys those kids who put so much
into it like
i'm just happy that the people involved
did everything that they could to create
the safest environment so those kids
could play again because the amount of
effort and forget the kids who are going
to the nfl those kids will be fine
right but the kids who play five years
at those schools and put so much into it
and earn scholarships and they have a
short window to play and once they're
done that's it like i'm just
i'm really really happy that those kids
like the fifth year seniors involved
these programs
get a chance to go out there and play
one last time and one one particular kid
i'll be rooting for
heavily uh this weekend is uh a walk-on
captain
at nebraska named kade warner kurt's son
he's got a c on his chest he's a captain
he is wow
on his way wow that's great you just
made my day that's fantastic
i remember talking with uh what occurred
about him when he was high school wow
he's a captain now how about that got a
c
on his chest and i'll be rooting for him
saturday at noon eastern
yeah for multiple reasons right
thanks for the call albert you take care
of yourself okay
all right thanks for watching good
morning the great albert breer here on
the rich eisen show